hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live ja wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt
wer ist das ich bin Philipp Wortmann bin
der Neue und jetzt hier häufiger für
euch am Start und ich freue mich sehr
dass ihr heute hier zu meiner Premiere
dabei seid wir schauen heute wieder auf
den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine bzw vor allem auf die Gegend
Offensive der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
diese gegen Offensive die läuft jetzt
seit gut acht Wochen und trotz aller
Schwierigkeiten soll es nun ein paar
entscheidende Fortschritte bei diesen
Kämpfen geben und sogar einen ersten
Durchbruch so ist das möglicherweise die
Wände wie schafft es die ukrainische
Armee aktuell offenbar da so
entscheidende Fortschritte zu erkämpfen
darüber spreche ich gleich mit dem
Militärexperten Michael Karl und wir
schalten in diesem Stream auch nach
Odessa in die Ukraine zu unserem
Reporter in der Region gab es nämlich in
der vergangenen Nacht wieder Angriffe
mit Drohnen und ihr kennt das Spiel für
euch gilt wie immer ihr könnt sehr gerne
hier eure Fragen stellen im Chat oder er
uns per Mail ihr könnt auch sehr gerne
eure Gedanken zum Thema mit uns teilen
wie gesagt das funktioniert sehr gut im
Chat wenn ihr bei Youtube zuguckt oder
ihr schickt uns die Fragen einfach an
die Mailadresse die er da eingeblendet
seht die lautet ZDF heute - live at
zdf.de und ich werde dann versuchen so
viele von euren Fragen und Gedanken wie
möglich hier im Stream unterzubringen
und ich habe es gerade schon versprochen
wir wollen jetzt sprechen mit dem
militär-experten Michael kahl der ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet aus Hamburg
Michael ist mit dieser Experte beim
gids das ist eine Think Tank der
Bundeswehr hallo Herr Karl hallo nach
Hamburg grüße Sie
schönen guten Abend
danke dass Sie sich die Zeit nehmen ja
Herr Karl lassen Sie uns gerne einfach
damit einsteigen also es gibt jetzt
diese Meldung dass die Ukraine in ihrer
Gegend Offensive offenbar deutlich
Fortschritte macht wie sieht es ihre
Einschätzung nach aktuell aus an der
Front
ja also auch das sind unsere
Erkenntnisse dass ich nach acht Wochen
nun eine eine andere Strategie wohl
durchsetzt eine andere Taktik in
Operationen der Ukrainer man hat
wahrscheinlich seine leeren auch
ausgezogen zumindest erkennbar dass nun
anders vorgegangen wird und dies auch
erfolgreich absolviert wurde im Moment
Herr Karl lass uns gerne einmal schauen
wir haben eine Karte auf der man das
glaube ich ganz gut einmal verdeutlichen
kann und das auch gut erkennt also diese
Fortschritte bzw die Stellen an denen
die ukrainischen Truppen gerade offenbar
die russischen Besatzer deutlich unter
Druck setzen das ist einmal bei der
Stadt und im Gebiet dann Netz bei welica
novos Ziel kam das sehen wir jetzt hier
gut auf der Karte bisher hieß es ja
immer sie haben gerade schon gesagt in
den vergangenen acht Wochen so richtiges
Vorankommen ist da irgendwie nicht was
ist jetzt auf einmal anders
also nach unseren Erkenntnissen haben
die Ukrainer ihre Erfahrungen gesammelt
in den ersten Wochen haben selber
mitbekommen und das war ja auch in den
Medien
[Musik]
nachvollziehbar das Vorgehen war relativ
langsam aber nun hat man die Taktik
geändert also das Vorgehen in Gruppen
verspricht doch mehr Erfolg als die
vorhergehende Taktik die angewandt wurde
nehmen Sie mich da gerne einmal ein
bisschen mit also sie sagen dass das
vorangehen in Gruppen wie muss man sich
sozusagen die Taktik vorher vorstellen
und wie sieht sie jetzt aus wenn Sie das
vielleicht einmal ein bisschen ausführen
könnten
sie haben ja die Karte auch vorliegen
wenn Sie die russischen stellungssysteme
die ja auch bei anderen Think Tanks auch
zu lesen sind und auch die Karten die
man da studieren kann dann stellt man
doch fest dass die russischen
Streitkräfte ein umfassendes
stellungssystem
gespickt mit vielen Minenfeldern
aufgebaut haben hier hat man
Erkenntnisse gewonnen und geht nun
anders vor heißt also gegenseitige
Deckung
raubmartiges Vorgehen beziehungsweise
überschlagendes Vorgehen
man nutzt auch
Militärgerät wo man Minenfelder
unschädlich machen kann bzw Gassen
hineinspringen kann umso besser
vorzukommen also
es ist fast natürlich in Kriegen das in
einer Konfliktsituation Erkenntnisse
gewonnen werden und wenn man nicht voran
konnte da muss man etwas ändern und das
hat die Ukraine gemacht und die
ukrainische Armee
hier ein Vorteil dass die russischen
Streitkräfte fest sind in ihren
Stellungen das heißt die Flexibilität
ist beim Angriff der ukrainischen Kräfte
und Sie können natürlich entsprechend
variieren und das ist hier gerade der
Fall
über die Minenfelder die es auch in der
Vergangenheit den ukrainischen Truppen
schwer gemacht haben vorzurücken
sprechen wir auch noch im Laufe dieses
Streams auch gerne noch einmal sie uns
gerade angesprochen die Verfassung der
russischen Truppen wenn wir noch einmal
wirklich vielleicht die Karte in den
Blick nehmen die wir gerade gesehen
haben warum sind es gerade diesen diese
beiden Orte bzw auch dieses Gebiet dabei
doch Netz das ist eben gerade da den
ukrainischen Truppen wirklich macht da
weiter vorzudringen wieso schaffen sie
es gerade da
ja wir haben da eine
einen besonderen Blick auf die
russischen Großverbände die dort
eingesetzt worden sind oder derzeit
eingesetzt werden zum einen ist das die
58 Armee und wir wissen ja aus den
Medien vor einigen Wochen dass der
Kommandeur general Ivan Popov ein sehr
populärer ein sehr beliebter Kommandeur
bei seiner Truppe ist durch seine
Offenheit
abgesetzt worden also das hat auf jeden
Fall schon mal Auswirkungen auf
Motivation und gefechtswert der
russischen Truppen bzw der Soldaten der
58 Armee
wobei da noch hinzukommt dass diese
Armee schon über Wochen in diesem
gefechtsabschnitt eingesetzt worden ist
und vielleicht noch einen mittleren bis
niedrigen Kampf Wert hat und jetzt
natürlich durch die Absetzung ihres
beliebten Kommandos noch zusätzlich
weniger Motivation hat dort zu kämpfen
bei der zweiten durchbruchsabschnitt
oder möglichen durchbruchsabschnitt der
fünften Armee handelt es sich um Teile
die aus allen Teilen des militärbezirks
Süd und Ost zusammengezogen worden sind
also eine Truppe die mehr oder weniger
zusammengewürfelt wurden ist auch da ist
es schwierig
ein Kampf fährt so hochzusetzen wie ein
eingespieltes Team eine Armee die von
Grund auf aufgebaut worden ist sondern
hier handelt es sich wirklich um eine
zusammengewürfelt Armee nach unseren
Erkenntnissen
kann man daraus dann schlussfolgern dass
sozusagen der aktuelle Erfolg der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte
von der Schwäche ein Stück weit ist es
ja auch logisch der der russischen
Kräfte profitiert
ja da gehen wir von außen also genau
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte oder das
Hauptquartier das Headquarter
entsprechend eruiert hat da sind die
Schwachpunkte der russischen
Streitkräfte im gesamten System und dort
greifen wir an also man darf ja auch
nicht vergessen dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte in der ersten Phase der
Angriffsbewegung etwa 25% ihrer Verbände
erst eingesetzt hat die Reserven sind
weitaus höher und können natürlich jetzt
mit Nachdruck auch eingesetzt werden
dazu passt sehr gut eine Frage die wir
bekommen haben bei Youtube von gähn
wegtreten welche Truppen und in welcher
Stärke sind denn an dem Durchbruch
beteiligt bzw welche Aufgabengebiete
hatten die und wie hoch sind wir
Verluste an Personal und Material
vielleicht schauen wir uns erstmal den
ersten Teil der Frage an also haben sie
Erkenntnisse darüber welche
Truppen und in welcher Stärke an diesen
Fortschritten jetzt gerade beteiligt
sind
also es sind die klassischen Elemente
des landkrieges die eingesetzt werden
also hier sind es Panzer und
infanterieverbände die eingesetzt werden
gleichzeitig in Kombination mit
Unterstützung durch Pioniereinheiten und
durch Artillerie Einheiten
die Stärke kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen
und das entzieht sich auf meiner
Kenntnis aber wenn Sie einen Angriff
dort durchführen dann sind das die
Visionen die da eingesetzt werden also
in einer Stärke von ca zwischen 10 und
12.000 pro division
kann man das ins Verhältnis setzen wie
hoch aktuell das war ja auch ein Teil
der Frage wie hoch aktuell die Verluste
sind möglicherweise auch sozusagen im
Verhältnis bei der Seiten
also über die Verlustzahlen kann ich
nichts sagen
man geht aber immer in einer Rechnung
davon aus in einem solchen Gelände was
so anspruchsvoll ist sollte der Angriffe
Greifer eine 4 zu 1 Überlegenheit
gegenüber dem Verteidiger haben ja also
das ist die die ungefähr Berechnung die
man macht was sie Verlustzahlen angeht
so möchte ich mich darauf nicht
festlegen weil da die Zahlen auch
ziemlich ungenau sind da möchte ich
keine Aussage zu machen
die gegen Offensive der Ukraine die ging
ja in den vergangenen Wochen nur sehr
schleppend voran ein wesentlicher Grund
ist eben dass die russische Armee ganze
Landstriche verdient hat warum ist so
schwer und auch gefährlich ist dadurch
zu kommen das hat mein Kollege Pablo sie
lalai für euch zusammengefasst
ukraineische Truppen im Gefecht dass die
gegen Offensive so mühsam ist liegt auch
an den vielen russischen Minen in der
Ukraine die zu beseitigen ist
zentimeterarbeit ein ukrainischer
minenräume bereitet sich in der Nähe von
saporicia auf seinen Einsatz vor für die
Räumtrupps kann im Ernstfall jeder
Schritt tödlich sein deshalb müssen sie
spezielle Schutzkleidung tragen
ich trage spezielle Stiefel keine Ahnung
welches Land die hergestellt hat aber
sie sind extrem wichtig für uns weil
wenn jemand auf eine Mine treten sollte
eine PFM oder PMN dann würden diese
Stiefel die Beine des minenräubers
retten
pfm-pmn Abkürzungen die den Tod bedeuten
können besonders perfide sogenannte
springminen vom Typ POM diese
explodieren nicht im Boden sondern
springen zuerst in die Luft und
explodieren in geringer Höhe so dass
ihre scharfkantigen Splitter in einem
Radius von 10 Metern wirksam sind und
damit besonders tödlich Hoffnung bietet
die sogenannte pyrotechnische
Minenräumung aus der Ferne sie wird von
beiden Seiten benutzt hier Bilder des
russischen Militärs bei diesem Verfahren
werden an einer Linie verbundene
Sprengladungen auf das Minenfeld
platziert und dort kontrolliert zur
Explosion gebracht
Herr kalt daran schließt sich eine Frage
auch gut an die wir bei Youtube bekommen
haben von the all of Porridge der wird
gefragt Herr Karl wird sie veränderte
Taktik ermöglicht durch einen
veränderten Einsatz der westlicher
Waffensysteme oder wurden neue Systeme
geliefert die die Minenfelder besser
durchbrechen können
ist eine sehr gute Frage nach unseren
Erkenntnissen spielt alles eine Rolle in
diesen in dieser jetzt veränderten
Offensive es ist natürlich wichtig
verschiedene Waffensysteme oder auch
gute erprobte Waffensysteme zu haben
aber es liegt natürlich auch im
Wesentlichen daran dass die Kommandeure
und die militärischen Führer
entsprechende Erkenntnisse gewinnen und
dadurch ihre Truppen flexibler und
besser einsetzen können also von allem
etwas diese Melange muss da sein um
erfolgreich den Durchbruch zu schaffen
also ein Zusammenspiel vieler Faktoren
eine Meldung die ich gerne noch einmal
kurz mit Ihnen besprechen würde bevor
wir zu unserem Korrespondenten zu
unserem Reporter in der Ukraine schalten
es gibt die Meldung von britischen
Geheimdienst das Russland aktuell im
großen Stil neue Kampfeinheiten
ausbildet über den Zustand der
russischen Truppen haben wir schon kurz
gesprochen was sagt das tatsächlich aus
wie ist das zu bewerten
das sagt aus das Russland sehr hohe
Verluste bereits hat und diese Verluste
jetzt ausgleichen muss also es ist
erkennbar einen fünf Militärbezirken die
arg ausgedünnt sind die fünf
militärbezirke über Russland gezogen und
man braucht mehr Soldaten man braucht
die junge Männer an der Front weil halt
die alten erfahrene bereits alle
gefallen sind
Herr Karl danke Ihnen für den Moment wir
sprechen uns dann gleich noch mal wieder
ja während die ukrainische Armee
offenbar Erfolge erkämpft gegen die
russischen Angriffe weiter in der
vergangenen Nacht sind laut russischen
Angaben
ukrainischen Angaben so ist es richtig
russische Truppen in der Region Odessa
eingeschlagen und zwar im Donauhafen
Ismael und in der Stadt Odessa ist jetzt
mein Kollege Dara Hassan Sade
da sehen wir ihn mit Moped im
Hintergrund hallo Sarah grüß Dich
hallo
nimm uns gerne einmal mit was ist da in
der vergangenen Nacht passiert in der
Region Odessa
ja also der die erste Warnung von
Luftangriffen kam in der Nacht kurz nach
eins sie wurde dann intensiviert und auf
die Region oblässer und deshalb
konzentriert und
interessanterweise sind die Drohnen
erstmal Richtung Stadt geflogen Richtung
der Stadt Odessa so dass du vermuten
waren dass die Hafenanlagen die entweder
direkt in der Stadt liegen oder in dem
näher in der Nähe näheren Umfeld in den
außen Bezirken ziel dieser Luftangriffe
sein könnten doch dann treten sie ab und
flogen den Westen in Richtung Ismael dem
Donauhafen und das war auch dann das
eigentliche Ziel dieses Angriffes ob das
jetzt eine Taktik warum erstens die Luft
die Luftabwehr in norddeter zu
alarmieren und die in Ismaning in
Sicherheit zu wagen oder ob das andere
Gründe für diesen Flughafen das weiß ich
jetzt von hier aus nicht entscheidend
ist aber das ähm insgesamt in über der
Ukraine 23 drohen nur abgeschossen
wurden
das wurde von der ukrainischen Armee
gesagt und es gab massive Einschläge in
der hafenstruktur von Ismael und ist von
großer Bedeutung für die Ukraine denn
das ist der ausweich heilhafen seitdem
das kreideabkommen beendet wurde von
russischer Seite denn von dort aus ging
die dass die Hauptachse des Getreide
Exportes im Moment für die Ukraine
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
als Reaktion bei telegram geschrieben
russische Terroristen haben erneut Häfen
getreideanlagen und die globale
Ernährungssicherheit ins Visier genommen
du hast es gerade schon angeschnitten
aber erklär uns doch bitte einmal noch
kurz warum ist der Hafen Ismael so ein
besonderes Ziel im Moment
weil der Hafen Ismail haben die Ukraine
und die ganze Infrastruktur auch
ausgebaut um eben genau für den Fall
dass die Seehäfen des schwarzen Meers
nicht mehr angefahren werden können eine
Exportmöglichkeit für Getreide hat zu
haben und das hat eigentlich auch gut
geklappt
der Vorteil dieses Hafens ist es in
unmittelbarer Nähe zu zu Rumänien das
ist ein nato-land das heißt Luftangriffe
für Russland bergen das Risiko dass sie
direkt wenn sie so unpräzise sind wie
sie sich oft dargestellt haben in diesem
Krieg dann eine nato-land treffen können
und dann können diese kleineren Schiffe
über rumänische Gewässer nach konstanter
fahren und dort am Hafen dann für den
Welthandel bereitgestellt werden die
Lieferungen aus der Ukraine deswegen ist
der von so großer Bedeutung in den
letzten neun Tagen ist ähm hat die
russische Armee oder die russischen Luft
Angriffe über 180.000 Tonnen Getreide
zerstört durch Angriffe aufgetreide
Lager diese dieses Getreide war
natürlich zum Essen bestimmt und zum und
zum Export deshalb diese ähm
wie soll man sagen doch sehr
klare Warnung von selenski an die Welt
ist betrifft nicht nur die Ukraine
sondern dieses Getreide ist eigentlich
für andere Länder bestimmt
die Stadt die Stadt Odessa in der du
jetzt gerade bist die ist ja auch ebenso
wie die Region in der Vergangenheit auch
immer wieder das Ziel von
Drohnenangriffen gewesen du bist ja
schon eine Weile vor Ort und spricht
natürlich auch mit Menschen die da sind
dieser Leben wie wie geht es den wie ist
deren Gefühl auch wenn sie jetzt
möglicherweise von den Erfolgen hören
die an der an der Front da erkämpft
werden können wie ist die Stimmung
aktuell
ich denke dass das was Sie erfolgreicher
Freund angehen speziellen an speziell an
dieser langen Südfront von Frau rieche
bis zur sogenannten beritianz Front
weiter im Osten dass dieser Erfolge im
Moment jetzt noch nicht so Euphorie
Schüben ausreichen aber es war auch
vorher so dass sie Erwartungen hier in
der Ukraine bei den Ukraine nicht so
riesig ausgeprägt war wie es vielleicht
im Westen der Fall war weil der doch
viele Menschen im Westen glaubten wenn
dann mal der Leopard geliefert sei oder
der Mörder dann wäre ja alles was der
Eroberung von ähm die Rückeroberung von
russisch besetzten Gebieten an gegen
quasi eine Formsache die den Menschen
hier war das bewusst dass das sehr
schwer wird dass es viele Menschen leben
kosten wird
jede Familie hat
Verwandte Brüder die Väter die in der
Armee kämpfen die das erste Hand
fronterlebnisse hatten und das schon
seit über 500 Tagen von daher weiß man
hier sehr wohl was Krieg und
Rückeroberungen bedeutet und wenn ich
das jetzt noch kurz sagen darf sie
wissen aber auch um was es geht
gerade vorhin hatte ich noch
Gespräche
mitbekommen in den Leute von ihren
Verwandten auf der in russisch besetzten
Gebieten Sprachen und wie wichtig also
wie wichtig ist diesen Familien ist dass
die zurückerobert werden und dass das
lange dauert wissen Sie dass es sich
lohnt aber auch weil sie ja von den ähm
Zuständen dort die hören wenn man zum
Beispiel keinen russischen Pass annimmt
sondern auf seinem ukrainischen Pass
behaart dann ist man von vielem
ausgeschlossen medizinischer Versorgung
Zugang zu Behörden und so ähm
unterdrückt die russische Seite all
diese Menschen die weiterhin zur Ukraine
gehören wollen die jetzt im russisch
besetzten Gebiet sind dennoch höre ich
da einen vorsichtigen Optimismus bei den
Menschen raus jetzt angesichts dieser
Meldung die ist von der Front gibt habe
ich dich da richtig verstanden
ja natürlich hofft hier jeder auf
Erfolgsmeldung und seien sie noch so
klein werden diese natürlich freudig
aufgenommen aber es ist nicht
vergleichbar mit der Situation als zum
Beispiel herrson befreit wurde oder als
zum Beispiel ismium zurückerobert wurde
wo große Gebiete dann auf einmal befreit
waren weil die Erfolge halt eher
strategischer Natur sind wie ja eben im
vorherigen Teil der Sendung erklärt
wurde
Sarah ich würde gerne dir noch einmal
kurz zum Schluss eine Frage weitergeben
die uns bei Youtube erreicht hat die
wollen wir nicht unter den Tisch fallen
lassen und zwar von asb Emskirchen da
wird gefragt nachdem wie weit von der
rumänischen Grenze sind die Drohnen in
der vergangenen Nacht eingeschlagen
kannst du das einschätzen
ich habe ja die Fotos gesehen von den
Anlagen die getroffen wurden und ich war
vor jetzt ungefähr zehn Tagen selbst in
Israel und habe dort gedreht wir reden
da Luftlinie
in manchen Fällen schon von einer sehr
kurzen Distanz schätzen das muss jetzt
sagen das jetzt mein augenmaßen was ich
Schätzung angeht denke ich mal so der
direkte Grenzposten wäre vielleicht
zweieinhalb Kilometer
alles klar danke dir daran Dara Hassan
Sade mein Kollege in Odessa danke und
alles Gute für dich
so und wir sprechen jetzt noch mal mit
dem Militärexperten vom gids Michael
kahl an dieser Stelle und haben einige
Kommentare von Euch erreicht dass die
Tonqualität bei dem Gespräch leider
nicht ganz optimal ist wir haben bei der
Leitung nach Hamburg ein paar technische
Probleme großes Sorry dafür wir sind
dran und versuchen das irgendwie zu
fixen und ja bitten euch an der Stelle
um Entschuldigung und da ist auch wieder
Herr Karl
und er hört mich wunderbar Herr Karl ähm
wir haben jetzt gerade über Drohnen
Angriffe gesprochen auf ukrainischen
Boden es gab jetzt aber auch in der
Nacht zu gestern also von vorgestern auf
gestern laut russischen Angaben Angriffe
auf einen Büroturm in einem
Geschäftsviertel in Moskau es gab nach
russischen Angaben keine Verletzten
Russland macht die Ukraine
verantwortlich für diesen Angriff man
fragt sich jetzt
Drohnenangriff auf Russland auf Moskau
moskau ist ziemlich weit entfernt von
der ukrainischen Grenze wie kann das
überhaupt sein wie schätzen Sie das ein
oh das ist durchaus möglich
thronentypen die also viele
lightroonentypen die eingesetzt werden
in diesem Krieg auch von Seiten der
Ukraine haben durchaus die Kapazität das
ist so weit fliegen können dass sie auch
durchaus Moskau angreifen können
und
ich weiß auch von einem Beispiel wo eine
alte Tupolev 114 Drohne eingesetzt
worden ist bei Engels 2 das ist ein
Flughafen 400 km von der ukrainischen
Grenze wo also auch zielgerecht
russische Transportflugzeuge getroffen
worden sind also diese Möglichkeit ist
durchaus möglich
die Frage die sich aber stellt ist also
wir sehen jetzt wir haben gerade die
Bilder gesehen es gab einen nicht
unerheblichen Sachschaden es sind
offenbar zum Glück keine Menschen
verletzt worden können diese Drohnen die
dann in Moskau einschlagen wirklich auch
zur Bedrohung für Russland werden oder
was steckt dahinter
ich denke es ist eher ein
ein psychologischer Effekt der dabei ist
also moskau ist nicht unverletzbar
moskau ist nicht
unerreichbar
dieser Effekt könnte oft schon
ausreichen um entsprechend auch die
moskau-bevölkerung Unsicherheit zu
wiegen also das ist durchaus möglich
dass wenn man hiermit auch zeigen
ich würde gerne noch einen Vorfall mit
Ihnen besprechen der sich gestern
zugetragen hat und zwar wurden zwei
Militärhubschrauber die sollen von
Belarus aus in den polnischen Luftraum
eingedrungen sein da sehen wir sie
gerade im Bild die polnische und das in
sehr niedriger Flughöhe so und die
polnische spanische
Verteidigungsministerium das sieht darin
eine gezielte Provokation Polens und
eine Verletzung eine Provokation der
Ostflanke der NATO wie bewerten Sie
diesen Vorgang
ja da geht den verschiedenen Richtungen
die Bewertung des Vorgangs zum einen es
kann durchaus der Fall sein dass eine
Provokation
inszeniert wird von Seiten Weißrusslands
als enger alliierter
Russlands und Moskaus um damit etwas
auszulösen vielleicht den Abschuss durch
polnische Einheiten weil diese
Hubschrauber nur mal Territorium
verletzt haben es könnte durchaus sein
dass es aber auch nur
sehen will wie die Reaktion Polen sein
würden nun Polen hat entsprechend
reagiert zu Recht reagiert aber sie
haben nicht geschossen das ist schon mal
ein guter Schritt in die richtige
Richtung weil eine solche Provokation
man möchte damit natürlich etwas
suggerieren nämlich dass er natuland von
Weißrussland zwei Hubschrauber abschießt
als Beispiel um damit zu sagen hier die
Natur hat uns angegriffen könnte man so
auslegen ja
halten Sie solche so ähnliche
Provokationen in Zukunft weiter für
denkbar
auf jeden Fall
Herr Karl dann lassen Sie uns gerne zum
Schluss noch einmal schauen wir haben
viele Kommentare bekommen zu diesem
Thema die ich gerne noch in Teilen an
Sie weitergeben würde und zwar schreibt
Mario bei Youtube bis wann sollte die
Ukraine den Versuch des großen
Durchbruchs spätestens unternommen haben
um vor der Regenzeit im Oktober
nennenswerte Gelände Gewinne erzielen zu
erzielen und absichern zu können
also das ist tatsächlich das ist
tatsächlich ein Problem die der Herbst
Regen und der
frühjahrsregen in dieser Region wobei
der Verteidiger und Angreifer
gleichzeitig in Schwierigkeiten bringt
also bis Ende September sollte der
Erfolg sich abzeichnen
um dann in eine sogenannte flexible
Verteidigung überzugehen also
errungenes Land zu halten oder erobert
das Land zu halten
notfalls auch ein Teil wieder
zurückzugeben und dann wieder neu
anzusetzen im neuen Jahr so ist
tatsächlich eine eine Möglichkeit der
Berechnung des ganzen
es gibt noch eine Frage von Falk
Gebhardt der schreibt sehen Sie die in
Deutschland Gelehrten Strategien und
Taktiken durch die bisherigen
Erfahrungen im Ukraine kriegt als
bestätigt oder veraltet
also erstmal sollte man
so ansetzen dass ukrainische wie auch
russische Soldaten oder Offiziere oder
militärische Führer natürlich nach den
Prinzipien
zum Beispiel der Militärstrategie von
1962 ausgebildet worden sind und das ist
auch artgleiche in beiden Armeen
natürlich haben die ukrainischen Kräfte
eine andere Ausbildung im Westen
bekommen also auch nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern auch in
Großbritannien und den USA und da sind
alle Möglichkeiten entsprechend
ausgebildet worden
die Frage zieht wahrscheinlich dahin
aber die ist ausgelegt auf die deutschen
Kräfte erstmal in der Verteidigung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und da stehen
wir nach wie vor relativ modern da wenn
man das natürlich jetzt überträgt in den
Angriff der Ukraine auf russische
Stellung oder auf das
Gebiet oder in Richtung der Krim dann
muss man abwägen dann muss man abwägen
ich denke dass man das nicht eins zu
eins übertragen kann und als veraltet
oder als besonders modern ansehen kann
das ergibt sich aus der Lage jeweils
jetzt stellt bei Youtube F David B
natürlich die ganz große Frage und zwar
wie schätzen Sie die Chancen zum Erfolg
dieser Großoffensive ein und ab wann
könnte man von einem substanziellen
Erfolg von ukrainischer Seite sprechen
wie ist da ihre Einschätzung
der Erfolg ist dann da
wenn die Krim wieder Ukrainisch ist und
der Donners ebenfalls wieder Ukrainisch
ist
fragen Sie dafür eine zeitliche Prognose
oder kann man da ein Szenario skizzieren
wie das passieren könnte sie schütteln
den Kopf
also das erstens habe ich keine
Kristallkugel hier die dass ich das
Voraussagen könnte aber
da haben alle möglichen zeitlichen
Möglichkeiten haben da Platz für das
kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen ich hoffe der
Krieg ist bald vorbei
dann danke ich Ihnen an dieser Stelle
für die vielen anderen Einschätzungen
und Informationen nach Hamburg Michael
Carl Militärexperte beim Think Tank der
Bundeswehr gids danke schön alles Gute
nach Hamburg
und ein Blick in die Kommentare der
sehen wir noch Lob das nehmen wir noch
gerne mit das kommt von radevortex danke
dass wichtige Fragen immer beantwortet
werden dafür sind wir gerne da und den
dank den gebe ich auch gerne an Euch
zurück danke fürs mit diskutieren danke
für eure Fragen hier in diesem Stream
zur ukrainischen Gegend Offensive und
bis bald macht's gut danke